yesterday we traded max pacioretty and
dylan coughlin to
the carolina hurricanes and a move that
was
designed to create
space on our salary cap
and enable us to make some corresponding
moves
i think you'll notice if you look around
the national hockey league over the last
months
almost every trade that has taken place
has had
salary cap implications it's a real
uh challenging
aspect for teams across the league and
that's how
we chose to manage it
you'll notice if you
look at our roster we needed to create
some flexibility to sign some young
players who have become big parts of our
hockey club
the restricted free agents
nick hague
brett howden
nickwa
the contract to zach white cloud which
kicks in
for the coming season
i think those are really important
players to a team
that's in a salary cap world that's
going to be at the salary cap those guys
are big contributors
for our organization
the final move that we made was signing
riley smith to a three-year contract
we felt this was extremely important to
keep riley in our organization he's a
day one knight
he represents everything that we stand
for he's an exceptional two-way player
one of our captains and
a player that is an exceptional two-way
player at this point in his career so
those were the moves that uh that were
made yesterday i'd like to thank max and
dylan for their contributions
to our organization i think in the case
of dylan he's going to get opportunity
in carolina that he uh perhaps might not
have received here and i think in the
case of max a real solid contributor to
our organization for
uh four seasons elite goal scorer that i
know is going to do really well
in carolina we wish both players the
very best